welcome back guys in this quick tutorial
i want to share with you how to unlock
true cinematic motion blur in after
effects
and how the default motion blur in after
effects is as used to it as we've gotten
is actually super janky and you should
just never use it again alright so to
give credit where credit's due
right before andrew kramer kicked me off
the couch when we filmed vfx artist
react he pulled us all aside
and he was like hey let me show you guys
something cool and he just pulled this
out of his back pocket and it blew
our minds and it was this motion blur
tutorial so
shout outs to the king for keeping us
all employed and big thanks to
today's sponsor for this video is
skillshare if you guys want to learn
more about how to get two free monthly
skillshare for free
stick around to the end so what's the
main difference between
in-camera motion blur and after effects
default motion blur let me demonstrate
for you guys real quick so
um right now i'm at a 320 shutter speed
which means there's not much motion blur
so if i
swipe fast enough i might be able to get
a motion blur streak and you can see
that in the streak the brightness level
is maintained from the start
all the way to the finish okay but if i
were to do it in after effects and apply
like real smart motion blur
or force motion blur it's totally gonna
wash out
that highlight streak and it's going to
stop us from
creating shots that look realistic that
look like they were shot in camera
this this tip is actually super easy
it's very simple let's hop into after
effects
and figure it out hey if you guys are
enjoying these educational vfx videos
i'd love to ask you a favor go ahead and
leave a comment down below what do you
guys
want to learn next i have a lot of fun
putting these together and if you guys
aren't subscribed already then
definitely do so i got a lot of really
cool stuff coming out a surface
imperfections tutorial where we're
actually going to
make our own surface imperfections from
scratch
it's gonna be a lot of fun so definitely
don't miss out on that all right so i
got some pretty shaky
reference footage here my buddy cliff on
his onewheel
this is the in camera motion blur this
is what we're trying to match in after
effects
and i shot another version of the shot
with a high shutter speed so we got no
motion blur
and we want to add some so in my case
i'm using real smart motion blur you can
use time warp you can use
force motion blur whatever i'm going to
go ahead and check that and you can see
if we choose a correct frame here that
yep they're washed out just like our
example in the beginning of the video
so what we need to do to punch these
highlights up it's very simple
this is just a duplicated composition i
hadn't changed anything yet
let's go ahead and add an exposure
effect
and put it above the real smart motion
blur here's what we want to do we just
want to take the gamma correction
and bring it all the way down as far as
it'll go that's point
one and we'll want to duplicate
that effect and bring it down outside
the real smart motion blur
so essentially you have these two
exposure effects sandwiching
your your blur right let's take that
gamma correction
and go all the way back up past
one to ten all right so
at this point if i were to take a
snapshot
turn off the effects here and reveal my
snapshot
nothing should change so those
exposures have essentially canceled each
other out alright
but if i turn them on and then we turn
on the real smart
you can see that we have those beautiful
highlights preserved if i turn the
exposure effects on and off
you can see the difference so the
difference is huge
let's take a snapshot again turn those
exposures back on
and flip back and forth between the two
yeah so all of these highlights are
preserved looks really nice and if we
compare
it to the in-camera reference
it is not too far off actually all right
so now let's take it to the next level
so let's say that your shot is actually
pretty smooth i i stabilized one of
these here
and you want to add some post camera
shake
so it's basically the same setup you're
going to sandwich
your transform effect with those two
exposures
and i have a pretty simple wiggle
expression on the position here and
that's controlling our camera shake
and the exposures are saving those
highlights
again if i turn this off
and on you can see the difference here
totally a huge difference in those
highlights and for some reason when
you're using the transform method here
and adding
post shake you can still be in eight
bits per channel and it'll still work
just fine i guess it's just a real smart
motion blur version
needs those uh 32 bits per channel
and as a final step if you guys want to
save this as a preset
go ahead and select all these effects
from top to bottom i'm holding shift
animation save animation preset and save
it out as whatever you want
just make sure that it's put in the
correct folder here i dropped it into
image utilities as true motion blur and
you can go ahead and select the preset
and drag it on to your footage
and it'll be applied so you don't go
through all that trouble all over again
send this video to as many effects
artists as you can they could use this
tip
so we can all elevate our game together
and shout outs to skillshare for
sponsoring this video for us
they've offered you guys two free months
of skillshare premium for free just by
clicking the link
down below if you don't know what
skillshare is it's an online learning
community for creatives like you guys
who are looking to up their game
it doesn't matter if you're looking to
learn photoshop after effects cinema 4d
blender
unreal engine if you can type it into a
search bar you can learn it
so go check it out and get your learn on
for less than 10 bucks a month
or get it for free the first 1000 people
who click the link
down below get skillshare premium for
free for two months
so guys let's keep learning let's keep
elevating and growing our value together
my name is clinton jones see you guys
next time
[Music]
you